os resulta familiar este sonido verdad
seguro es la señal que indica que
profesores alumnos
tenemos que salir pitando de clase no
hubo ni entrar en otra
pasados unos minutos reina la calma y
que la profesora se encuentra en su aula
con sus alumnos impartiendo su
asignatura
pasan 50 minutos y se repite la historia
no son al timbre y alumnos y profesores
recorriendo los pasillos de gente y así
durante 7 horas al día
de tal forma que cada alumno tiene que
ponerse en distinto modo según la hora a
la que sea si suena el timbre y toca la
clase de biología te tienes que con el
modo biología y en ese momento pues te
ves aprendiendo el proceso de la
fotosíntesis
por ejemplo ostras persona el timbre
dichos o timbre y dejas de estar en
biología boom y te vas a verse de dibujo
y te pones en modo dibujo y en lo que te
encuentras allí es pues con los pinceles
no haciendo nos en los colores
secundarios
y así va pasando el tiempo y esos
timbres esas carreras y ese ponerse en
modo on era así hace 50 años hace 20 no
y hoy mismo
y si traducimos los cuatro años de la
eso en días son 720 5000 40 horas
conviviendo con el dichoso
pero así es como enviamos la información
a los alumnos y como ellos empaquetar el
conocimiento en parcelas aisladas en
trocitos en primero de la eso se
empaqueta así el segundo de la eso se
nota que está así en tercero y en cuarto
de tal forma que cuando un alumno una
alumna titula en cuarto era eso podemos
decir que tiene en su cabecita 5.040
paquetitos de conocimiento muy valiosos
en sí mismo pero sin ningún tipo de
conexión entre sí
esto también ocurre en los claustros de
profesores somos decenas de docentes
cada una una especialidad pero que tanto
la información que enviamos a los
alumnos como la que muy de vez en cuando
intercambiamos con los compañeros pues
es también de parcela aislada para que
la isla yo de dibujo hablo con él de
inglés etcétera y siempre hablamos de mi
aula con mis alumnos y mi asignatura
yo llevo muchos años trabajando de profe
y estado pues en varios centros algunos
de ellos francamente muy distintos entre
sí pero lo que siempre he escuchado a
los propios y que tienen en común es que
siempre dicen es que los chicos de un
día no relacionan claro es que como no
vinculan es que estos chicos no conectan
pero quién conecta a sí y quien conecta
sí
a ver
papá noel me trajo visto seguro que lo
conocéis la mitad de lo que estamos aquí
somos vintage
o sea que la técnica de hacer el seguro
os lo voy a enseñar y extraer tiernos
recuerdos mira es un juego muy sencillo
el conector en conector 3 consiste en la
pila de petaca y dos terminales lo que
había que hacer era buscar entre que dos
conceptos existe relación de ambas
columnas mira por ejemplo aquí en el
químico llegó alguien el químico y
puntual quien químico veis se enciende
brujas que funciona y tú todavía conecte
poco con éste poco
una mañana de octubre de hace ya dos
años me encuentro en mi aula con mis
alumnos impartiendo mi asignatura y
hablaba en ese momento los chicos del
siglo 18 no se hablaba de las pinturas
negras de francisco de goya la verdad es
que no sé muy bien como lo hice en ese
momento se cayeron que lo que hice para
son ángel buenas puertas del ángel y
pudo escuchar perfectamente a mi
compañera historia que en el aula que
tenía junto a mí hablaba concretamente
también desde 18 pero del punto de vista
de la arquitectura y les hablaba además
de la construcción de museo del prado y
pensé que corearon o qué coincidencia
sonó el timbre en salir de clase y le
dije no te puedes imaginar lo que ha
pasado a mi compañera está hablando a
los chicos de goya y tiene escuchando a
ti hablar de juan de villanueva no y la
reestructuración urbanística del 18
bueno ya la un ratico curioso y tal y
les dije oye si al final yo voy a estar
hablando de arte el 18 en este aula y tú
de arquitectura en el gran lado porque
nos damos mañana la clase juntas y me
dijo pero qué dices mamarracha en que no
se paró un tabique
pues usted viene pues lo tiramos a mí de
bilbao un tabique me dura sujeto un
cubata en sucre también cubata
la verdad es que los ritmos un ráting
con aquello del tabique se marchó y yo
anduve un par de días dándole vueltas a
aquella ni pensé probablemente estrábica
de pladur no sea el más complicado de
tirar los muros difíciles de tirar son
los que tenemos que aquí eso sí que son
complicados o sea traigan una imagen a
ver qué os parece que veis ahí que os
parece que está ocurriendo pues tiramos
los muros
aquello que se supone que no se podía
tocar y cuanto menos derribar lo tiramos
y sabéis lo que pasó
no pasó absolutamente nada y pasó
absolutamente todo lo bueno que tiene
que pasar en educación
el aparente normalidad donde cualquiera
no éramos los mismos alumnos los mismos
profesores el mismo aula las mismas
asignaturas estas mismas mesas esas
verdes y sillas que llevan 300 años en
nuestros centros todo todo era igual
pero nada volvió a ser lo mismo
dijimos se acabó adiós a los muros se
acabó adiós a los límites entre
asignaturas adiós a los tiempos de 50
minutos adiós a los timbres y como no y
lo más importante adiós a trabajar solos
decidimos cambiar nuestra forma de
trabajar porque nos planteamos qué
ocurre si rompemos la línea que separa
las asignaturas qué ocurre si rompemos
la línea del conocimiento en aquella que
marca lo previsible hoy y que puede
ocurrir si empezamos a empaquetar el
conocimiento de una forma distinta
hoy y siempre de conectar el
conocimiento por parcelas independientes
lo activamos todo a la vez ostras y se
lo conectamos le decidimos como os decía
a cambiar nuestra forma de la clase y
ponernos a trabajar en equipo de verdad
no es de trabajar en equipo en clase y
te venga chicos el siguiente trabajo es
en equipo siempre ves que un alumno una
alumna que resoplando que diciendo ya
estamos otra vez con los dichosos
trabajitos en grupo a mí me toca pegarme
la paliza a trabajar estos tres no van a
hacer nada y al final del profe el
volverlo a todos
y además los otros usuarios cuando
podemos trabajar en equipo es que parece
que estuviéramos como castigando aquí él
lo va a hacer
y premiando a que él ya casi a priori
sabemos que no va a hacer nada
oye qué curioso esto de trabajar en
equipo precisamente somos el proceso de
los que pedimos al chico que trabaja en
equipo cuando nos ven trabajar en equipo
nosotros nunca
porque los profesores jamás nadie nos
enseñó a trabajar en equipo pero ni en
el cole en el instituto y en la
universidad
nunca pues se acabó con eso también en
mi centro hemos decido poner en marcha
lo que hemos llamado profesores y aulas
de puertas abiertas ya día de hoy en mi
centro las clases son de 120 alumnos
cuatro grupos de 3º de eso a los que
impartimos clases ocho profesores de
siete asignaturas distintas a la vez
todos juntos y los alumnos reciben
clases de lengua castellana literatura
gracia historia biología y geología
dibujo música inglés y educación física
todos a la vez y ya no es la clase de
mate ni la clase de lengua en la clase
historia no arreglase del siglo 11 o la
del renacimiento en la que pues a estar
escuchando a la vez hablar de la peste
de los mecenas de florencia de roma y de
muchacho de dante e incluso de copérnico
de que presta de sí aspiro
imaginad por un momento que estuvieras
en mi clase el día que hablamos no sé si
19 por ejemplo de mi compañera de
historia comenzaría hablando de la
segunda revolución industrial y del
imperialismo de cómo los países van a
otros continentes como el africano a
rescatar de él algunos elementos como
concretamente el caucho y mi compañera
de ciencias explicaré a los chavales que
el caucho fue utilizado para fabricar
los primeros neumáticos de esos
vehículos esos primeros automóviles de
la época y yo que soy de arte les
contaré a mis alumnos que monet y turner
no hacen por casualidad que los
protagonistas esos cuadros sean las
locomotoras ese invento también de la
época no y tampoco fue casualidad que
los hermanos lumière filmarán la primera
película de cine de la historia y fuera
precisamente la entrada de una
locomotora en una bonita estación de
francia y gracias al desarrollo químico
el impresionismo gozó de millones de
colores para poder expresar la luz que
de otra forma hubiera sido imposible
y los compositores dejan de componer de
forma lineal y pasan a componer a golpe
de impresión y alejandro dumas escribe
la dama de las camelias y sirve
precisamente inspiración a verdi cuando
escribe la traviata y también es el
momento de la reivindicación social del
lugar de la mujer y precisamente esta
semilla es recogida por el arte
contemporáneo y algunos artistas como va
para cruces no hacen esas imágenes
algunos franceses tan potentes de
mujeres dicen no nosotras las mujeres no
necesitamos ningún héroe
y mi compañera de inglés habla como no
de la figura de bertín aguas
ahora sí profesores trabajando en equipo
de verdad profesores que hemos preparado
la clase juntos profesores observando un
compañero en lo que hasta ahora nos
frontera infranqueable la puerta del
aula esa linde que no se podía traspasar
si un compañeros dando clase no puedes
entrar profanas lo sagrado
y esa sensación de linde y de frontera
también la percibe a los alumnos te
recuerdo que el primer día queríamos
clases y citamos a los chicos en mi aula
de dibujo
y bueno pues estamos echando los profes
y los vimos llegar a 120
buenos días chicos pasado y no pasaban
en el chico pasado y no pasaban y ya
digo pero vamos a ver se sabe por qué no
pasáis y no existe una alumna tímida
para qué es lo que nos va a pasar hemos
hecho algo malo ocho profes la aie la
jefa de estudios esperándolo bienvenida
algo malo bien me uno algo malo iba a
pasar y más es era el momento pues en el
aparente caos de esa clase de 128
personas surgió la magia del
conocimiento la magia del conocimiento
compartido entre profesores alumnos que
buscábamos tejer nuevas conexiones en
esto de aprender y de enseñar
he leído hace unos días que según los
últimos informes internacionales el 87
por ciento de los docentes españoles
jamás ha entrado en clase de otro
compañero abel o trabajar
y los centros educativos no deberían ser
el lugar en el que aprenden los alumnos
también debería ser el lugar el que
aprendemos los profesores y cómo
aprendemos los profesores
el mejor maestro de un maestro quien es
pues otro maestro y los profes
aprendemos observando dialogando
discutiendo evaluando nuestra práctica
docente pero sobre todo aprendemos
compartiendo compartiendo conocimiento
puede compartir también tiene tela es
como lo de trabajar en equipo
yo tengo una niña pequeña cuando por las
tardes voy con ella al parque escucho
unas cinco mil veces diarias
frases como venga déjale tu palaverde
que compartir que te dicen en el cole
que compartir pero compartir pero hasta
cuando en qué momento le decimos a los
hijos oa los alumnos te acuerdas que te
enseñe a compartir se acabó ya no se
comparte más ahora bien la vida en serio
en la que tú trabajas solito y tú te las
apañas no preguntamos a mis profesores y
charlamos y pensamos oye y si empezamos
a compartir y hacemos que la docencia
deje de ser una profesión aislada y pasa
a ser una profesión de colaboración
pues pasa exactamente lo que nos está
pasando a nosotros y es que así veis que
tiene sentido enseñar así si tiene
sentido engañar y que además te
ilusionas trabajando porque aprendes
mucho estos compañeros y que casi no te
ves trabajando de otra forma y sobre
todo te das cuenta que te encanta
trabajar el equipo llegue no está tan
mal como que te gusta no y trabajando en
la clase de esa forma es que los alumnos
conectan
y javi mi javi con esos pedazos de ojos
verdes que tiene que tener que conocerlo
en ese alumno que estuvo durante meses
sin venir a clase y al que yo
personalmente tuve que ir a su casa
llamada teléfono hace el favor de bajar
y venirse conmigo al instituto porque
tiene este titular el cuarto a la eso
por lo civil o por lo penal
s javier levanta la mano y exclama
ahora no entiendo eureka ahí está la luz
roja del conecta ahí está ahí están
pasará las amos en un 95 por ciento de
titulados en la eso ahí están sus
exámenes maravillosos en los que sin
darse cuenta están manejando términos
históricos artísticos y científicos como
os digo no casi casi sin apreciarlo y
ahí están sus respuestas cuando les
preguntamos por qué ahora sé que es
mejores notas y nos dicen que es que
ahora recuerdan mejor y no es que
recuerden mejor es que han conectado
conocimiento y ese conocimiento que los
profes les damos y ese conocimiento que
ellos adquieren es el andamiaje
fundamental de la educación pero lo fue
siempre lo es y lo será por mucho que
haya algunos por ahí que digan que como
toda la información está la red está un
grupo de un clic para el conocimiento no
es tan importante estamos yendo
en mi centro cambio aproximadamente al
año a la mitad y hemos estado la mira
del proceso de julio se van a otros
centros
dicho esto es profe los veo todos los
días de todas las mañanas de todo el
ciclo lectivo todos no pasan por la
puerta de jefatura ahí estoy yo buenos
días al que está al ver que tal vez
estos chicos hoy venga buen día y salvo
en alguna ocasión muy muy muy muy
esporádica yo no vuelvo a hablar con
ellos
el día a día es una apisonadora que pasa
por encima de todos nosotros a nivel
burocrático que anula cualquier
posibilidad y espacio para el diálogo y
es ahora en julio cuando venir a verme a
despedirse de mí a decirme que se van a
otros institutos a trabajar cuando en
esos cinco o seis minutos que tengo para
charlar con ellos
oye que me entero que son expertos en
cosas alucinantes la profesora de física
química me decía que durante muchísimos
años trabajado en el ser en suiza en el
centro de investigación nuclear
la trabajadora social es una actriz muy
reconocida en los teatros de la gran vía
de madrid
el profe de educación física ha sido
seleccionado tiene que español y ya ha
participado en los juegos olímpicos y yo
la jefa de estudios he sido la última en
enterarme y pienso y precisamente me
entero ahora cuando ya se va con todo lo
que podíamos haber aprendido todos ellos
y en los centros educativos los claustro
de profesorado puro tenemos escritores
artistas ingenieras arquitectas
antropólogos físicos químicas uno pudo
conviviendo un montón de horas al día
sin ningún tipo de conexión entre
nosotros
os voy a contar el pequeño secreto del
año y es que es donde me he propuesto ya
como objetivo casi vital profesional
que estos procesos que han llegado ahora
hace tres semanas al instituto están un
poco asustados por el método pero ya
veréis qué chulo
van pasando por mi beso truco de 11.2
preguntas te va a hacer la jefa de
estudios dime quién eres y qué sabes
hacer porque estoy convencida de que
vamos a aprender muchísimo de tiempo
las contaría si tuviera tiempo pero
tengo uno
y algunos hemos comentado cosas que se
va a hacer pero efectivamente creo que
tampoco se puede decir a quien tengo
miedo
bueno en una era en la que estaba no en
un mundo de fronteras abiertas de
apertura constante al exterior y de
intercambio de información las redes no
puede ser que el conocimiento siga
encerrada entre cuatro paredes y las
puertas bien cerradas no no puede ser
abramos las asignaturas abramos las
aulas abramos las puertas y contemos nos
todo lo bueno que se hace en los centros
educativos de este país y sólo entonces
por fin podremos hablar de nuestras
aulas nuestros alumnos y nuestras
asignaturas y gracias a trabajar esta
forma conectando ocurren cosas
maravillosas y este pasado de mes de
junio tenemos al hub y al piano tocando
una pieza barroca que tenía que haberlo
visto
porque ha comprendido lo que es el
barroco y sus expresiones no en las
artes la música literatura también la
ciencia y ya siempre dando la clase con
la puerta abierta a quien tris hará a
quien quiera el conocimiento es para
todo el mundo
deseando que la siguiente continúe esta
maravillosa aventura locura de seguir
aprendiendo y enseñando a cuantos
y se levanta de la silla no con una
pieza sonrisa porque hoy por fin hemos
podido decirle que ha titulado en 4º de
la eso contra todo pronóstico personal
porque él jamás se vio capaz de sacar
cuarto de la eso contra todo pronóstico
también familiar y también social y se
acercó a mí y me dice profe de esta
clase mucho salgo con intriga
y yo que soy de las que hay veces que
estoy en clase con ellos y es que lloro
de risa por las cosas que dicen las
cosas que hacen no puedo evitar llorar
de emoción porque en ese instante en ese
preciso instante soy consciente de la
afortunada que soy de tener la profesión
más bonita del mundo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]